tiempo para la información económica en
france 24 para ello contamos con nuestro
compañero jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
otra vez a este plato vamos a comenzar
con la guerra porque pasa factura a la
economía rusa así es que se presentaron
en rusia la cifra de inflación
interanual de marzo hasta el 25 de marzo
la inflación ahí se ubicó en 15 66 por
ciento este es el mayor dato interanual
desde septiembre de 2015 y superó los 14
como 53 por ciento de la semana pasada
según el ministerio de economía la caída
del rublo afectado por las sanciones de
occidente hizo que los precios
aumentaran precipitadamente los precios
de elementos para bebés hasta los
productos farmacéuticos continúan en
aumento aunque a un ritmo más lento que
las semanas anteriores el banco central
tenía un objetivo de inflación del 4 por
ciento y por ahora mantiene el tipo de
interés del 20 por ciento en marzo alta
inflación seguimos con más inflación
ahora en españa'
así decides que con la inflación
interanual acercándose al 10 por ciento
del presidente del gobierno español
pedro sánchez pidió apoyo al el aumento
de su país la inflación interanual en
marzo fue del 98 por ciento la más alta
desde 1985 sánchez afirma que se podrá
doblegar la inflación y estabilizar la
evolución del costo de la vida gracias
al plan nacional de respuesta a la
guerra aprobado ayer por el gobierno
este plan asciende a 17 mil 600 millones
de dólares la mayoría destinados en
avales crediticios del estado para
empresas y autónomos como bonos de
combustible asimismo cómo evitar el
despido de trabajadores que se basen en
el alto precio de la energía y limitar
el aumento de los precios de alquileres
de vivienda escuchamos un poco la
intervención de pedro sánchez en el
parlamento sus señorías porque hoy hemos
conocido el dato de la inflación que es
un mal dato que afecta a nuestra
economía a nuestra sociedad en
particular a los colectivos más
vulnerables en un 73 por ciento el alza
de los precios explica por el desbocado
precio de la energía y también de los
alimentos no elaborados y todo ello
exacerbado por la guerra de ucrania
bueno jorge más allá del impacto que
esta guerra pueda tener en américa
latina' y ya se están nombrando algunas
oportunidades para la región y entre
estas oportunidades está que la región
se convierta en uno de los exportadores
de los principales exportadores netos de
alimentos esto fue uno de los temas que
se discutieron durante la trigésimo
séptima conferencia regional de la
organización de la onu para la
alimentación y la agricultura allí se
planteó que la región puede consolidarse
como el primer exportador neto de
alimentos en el mundo si mejora su
producción para darnos una idea entre
ucrania y rusia producen el 30 por
ciento del suministro global de trigo el
20 por ciento del suministro mundial de
maíz y entre el 75 y el 80 por ciento
del aceite de semilla de girasol
escuchemos la intervención de máximo
torero el jefe de la fao
tenemos que invertir en aumentar la
resiliencia y aumentar la resiliencia no
es sólo tener instrumentos para hacer y
tener instrumentos de avanzada para
tener mecanismos de alerta temprana y
para prevenir las cosas que falten sino
también es tener capacidad de resistir
un choque lo tenemos que seguir
incrementando esas capacidades
diversificar nuestro portafolio de
ventas para que si un país cierra las
exportaciones tengamos otro país donde
podamos ir pero sin duda antes de que
comenzara esta guerra ya había otros
factores otros riesgos que amenazaban a
la región así es y es que según el
programa mundial de alimentos de
naciones unidas los huracanes y está y
ello está afectaron el alza de los
precios en centroamérica y
particularmente en honduras según la
agencia en ese país centroamericano unos
2,4 millones de personas viven en crisis
alimentaria incluso antes de la pandemia
los huracanes
honduras ya enfrentaba problemas de
inseguridad alimentaria pero estos
escenarios agravaron la situación según
el programa de elementos entre junio y
agosto de este año el número de personas
en crisis su emergencia alimentaria
aumentará a 2,6 millones de personas
a la persistencia de la falta de empleo
de las reservas de alimentos y a la
crisis mundial de suministros y en medio
de toda esta crisis que nos indican las
bolsas internacionales
empezamos en eeuu ahí la bolsa de nueva
york terminó a la baja por el
estancamiento de las conversaciones
entre rusia y ucrania en europa el dax
40 de fráncfort también cerró a la baja
tras el anuncio de los datos de la
inflación y las fallidas conversaciones
de paz en américa latina el índice
merval de la bolsa de comercio de buenos
aires cerró con una subida del 1 por
ciento tras dos jornadas consecutivas en
negativo
jose acabamos con la cifra del día la
cifra es 82 mil millones de dólares eso
costaron las inundaciones a nivel
mundial en 2021 la cifra es casi un
tercio de todas las pérdidas por
catástrofes naturales a nivel mundial
según informó la agencia de seguros es
swift de instituto una cifra que
seguramente aumentará si no frenamos el
cambio climático jorge muchas gracias
por este repaso a nuestros espectadores
les invitamos a que sigan conectados a
france 24
324 puntocom
[Música]